you know i hope ultimately the essenti
the extensions come out okay
either way i think cat's gonna be a
brunette for a week
disgusting which reminds me do you know
what it's time for
send the writers home this next story
writes itself seriously you're all fired
pack your things and get the hell out
[Music]
this will make your blood boil if you
have any blood left after it shoots out
of your eyeballs
this is an unbelievable story yet
somehow believable these days from the
new york post
wisconsin school district has filed
sexual harassment complaints against
three middle schoolers for calling a
classmate by a wrong pronoun
i know i know how are these kids
supposed to even know what a pronoun is
when they're too busy being taught about
how racist they are
priorities people
but this isn't some loony left-wing city
on either left coast this is a school
district in kyle wisconsin a city of
just 3 600 people talk about small larry
kudlow can fit that many people in his
steam room
and he's tried
have you got a court date for that yet
larry
anyway
but apparently school administrators
charged three eighth graders from the
keel middle middle school with sexual
harassment after an incident in april
where these kids refused to use they to
refer to a classmate who'd switched
pronouns a month before the so-called
incident i'll say it before and i'll say
it again the only time you should refer
to one person as they is if they are
over 400 pounds as in
as in they love pancakes or they are
blocking the fire exit
one of the accused kids moms or birthing
person to democrats
gives us the scoop
i received a phone call from the
principal over at the elementary school
for warning me letting me know that i
was going to be receiving an email
with sexual harassment allegations
against my son he said he's being
allegedly charged with sexual harassment
for not using proper pronouns i thought
it wasn't real i thought this has got to
be a gag a joke ah you and me both
but her son braden was indeed charged
and with what having a low tolerance for
bs
but this feels to me made up because
it's so on the nose in terms of
fulfilling our own criticisms of
wokeness it's like the government
sending out free crack pipes after i
already paid full price
but it's real i guess that's the world
we live in where the parodies we created
months ago are now suddenly real
in other words the far left is so insane
they're now predictable remember it was
five years ago that jordan peterson an
obscure canadian professor was
threatened with punishment at his
college for not adhering to new pronoun
guidelines he refused to comply and when
people heard his story he became a hero
which is easy to be in canada where your
only options for hero are peterson and a
freaking blackface
he predicted that rejecting compulsory
pronouns would end up becoming a crime
people laughed at him mainly because he
was right meanwhile here's a guy from
wisconsin institute for law and liberty
who's defending the accused students
claiming that misuse of pronouns is not
covered by title ix
title ix sexual harassment typically
covers things like
rape
dating violence
quid pro quo sexual favors right really
egregious stuff there's nothing even
remotely close to that alleged in this
case the charge against students for
sexual harassment is a is a extreme
abuse of the title ix process it's
totally inappropriate
and is totally being mishandled by the
school district totally very informative
tape there we're almost like a news
program
almost now the district sees the refusal
of a student to use pronouns as a form
of bullying and the district prohibits
all forms of bullying and harassment so
all forms of bullying isn't forcing
students to say what they don't believe
a form of bullying let me save you from
some unnecessary internal mental debate
and tell you the answer is yes
of course if the alleged victim student
had been teased then the school teachers
or principals should address it but now
with charges of sexual harassment which
can destroy reputations that's kind of
out of proportion like swatting a fly
with joy behar
and it shows you why so many parents
around the country are freaking out
now not only they have to worry about
crt or drugs and social media they got
to worry about some leftist a-hole
school administrator canceling the kid's
reputation before he or she is old
enough to have one
parents you're now called homophobic if
you don't want gender obsessed activists
teaching your kids about they and them
you're called domestic terrorists if you
openly question school lockdowns mass
mandates or the brainwash called crt
yes parents are terrorists although the
only way they blow themselves up is with
a high carb diet
and parents are now told you're a bigot
if you feel it's inappropriate having
drag queens do story time in class and i
agree keep that crap out of the schools
and where it belongs my house on a
saturday night
look i don't have kids they smell
but i am so pissed i'm thinking about
adopting
but just imagine when it moves beyond
the classroom
hi yes i'd like to speak to debra about
her extended warranty her my pronouns
are dirt and bag oh uh well anyway i'm
calling about your 1996 geoprism oh my
car identifies as a volt
as in revolt oh are you having trouble
with your electrical system the system
okay well anyway our warranty comes with
a free tire iron and jack and those come
in handy handy you ableist bastard also
it's not a car jack it's a car jill okay
uh thanks for your time sir
apparently they like dirt bag
better than they like cats
so we'll keep an eye on this story maybe
the charges will get dismissed maybe
it'll turn out there's more to it than
meets the eye one thing is for sure just
because it sounds absurd doesn't make it
false in today's world it's the absurd
that is now the norm no wonder parents
are pissed but don't wonder aloud or
merrick garland will investigate you
with the patriot act
let's welcome tonight
see furniture shops at fisher price
co-host of america's new rooms newsroom
and the five data burrito
[Music]
he's so rich his 401k has its own 401k
fox business host and former director of
the national economic council larry
kudlow
he has audiences on the edge of their
seats as they prepare to leave
writer and comedian jamie lisa
and she's like your appendix you can
live without it but has the potential to
kill
you foxus contributor cat tip
so uh dana i was like i i didn't believe
this story and it but it's like it's
true it's true what it does isn't it i
thought it was something from the
babylon bee yeah and it is
disturbing i i know somebody who
recently uh is an adult
well as an adult uh and was teaches uh
college and was required to put his
pronouns in the signature of his email
and he refused and he they were gonna
fire him really and so now you see that
it's coming down to this middle school
level it seems absurd but i'm glad that
we're talking about it and that you have
it here on your highly rated show so
that more people see it um but here's
the other thing when the when the guy
that's defending them was talking about
title ix and what title nine does
you think about
women's sports that title nine was
supposed to be also about women's sports
right and who is defending women's
sports now no one yeah i mean well very
few people even women who are in sports
yeah are not defending women in sports
and so the chipping away of title ix is
underway and we have to be aware of it
do something about it yeah it's titled
line has flipped it's no longer
protecting women it's about protecting
the next oppressed group which is true
men who have become women yeah with
their nine titles with their nine titles
yes exactly by the way i just got that
this is the virginia school district is
considering suspensious suspensions for
malicious misgendering
you know my pronoun is
f you
that was easy
to go to break on that one
uh jamie do you have pronouns in alaska
[Laughter]
we we really don't and um
i'll tell you something if this is a
real they said they said situation yes
[Laughter]
i'm so relaxed from larry's steam room
yes
my son is exactly this age yeah and i
feel like i know him and his buddies and
i would say dude my pronouns when i was
in middle school this is the nicest
thing you could be called yes my middle
schooler is like possibly he or she by
mistake like literally my pronouns were
like weirdo when they would uh yeah when
they would use my actual pronoun they
would go he is a little [ __ ] yes
yeah when they used it correctly it's a
it's like you said i thought i thought
100 percent bev lumbee yeah i thought i
thought it was fake and just in general
it's grammatically incorrect it's a it's
plural so it's like hey either treat
someone call someone exactly what they
want to be called and fail grammar or
and also this reminds me of like in
alaska do you know moose
is the plural of moose right yes
do they get offended isn't that crazy so
they had like a meeting and they were
like what should we make the plural and
someone was like what if we make it the
same word and then we can just go go
drink yes
but the the problem with this you don't
get enough information because it'd be
like you could be walking on the road
and someone could be like oh my god
moose and you're like that's fine it's
just you turn around it's a thousand
movies
[Music]
there's not enough information that is
brilliant because what you're saying is
the confusion is reversed yes yes i just
dawned on him because like
it's like you're telling kids to be
grammatically incorrect when they're in
school right call them they uh larry
what's going on with this world
you know what's interesting
these people ask you to um
respect these pronouns when you're not
actually using them like if i'm you and
i are talking i'd say so what are you up
to when you go hey nothing oh well me
i'm doing this i don't say he to you
it's like it's as though i'm only i only
use these pronouns when i'm not talking
about you which means you wouldn't even
hear it which means this is all a
manufactured pile of poop if you'll
pardon my peas
mr kudlow well it's the pronoun yes and
if the pronoun changes you're gonna
throw this kid in jail yeah or the kid's
gonna have a sexual harassment for the
rest of his or her life i'm afraid to
put a pronoun in front of him yes not at
all clear to me
but that's a serious thing pronouns
change so at the beginning of the year
you can call me
basically whatever you want to call me
okay yeah but then three months into the
semester
i might want you to call me something
different from what you called me
earlier and then you'll get violated
this is joe biden's
woke america this is how crazy it is
there's not one wit of common sense and
by the by does anybody care about the
kid
who's what 12 13 years old does anybody
care about i mean
parents very important merit garland the
attorney general doesn't like parents
they're all domestic terrorists how
about the kid
right and the kids as they interact with
each other so you can really scar them
for life i don't know if anybody cares
about that but i do and the worst thing
you do is give a young person the power
to like you know well
what i don't know what let's let's call
her pat or they pat pat they they're
they just got charged with sexual
harassment and pat now goes that's
pretty awesome i could do this to
everybody i mean if i had that power
when i was a kid i would have changed my
gender 12 times
you know speaking of changing genders
what is what does uh what dirtbag deb
how's she doing she doing all right yeah
i don't know her
um
i don't want people to know that i'm
capable of being that ugly
[Laughter]
i just want to know how you were able to
do both eyes going in opposite
directions i couldn't see anything yeah
i almost passed out
so
what if
these guys are just being jerks right
that's possible right it is possible
that they were because we don't know it
could have not been as simple as using
the wrong pronoun but maybe they were
being mean about it
uh it's still not sexual harassment
right to be mean to somebody
uh what i would like because when i was
in eighth grade everyone was mean to me
yeah and i oh like i agree with you i
almost wish i could go back in time and
become the richest child in the world by
suing people right yeah i missed out on
that but it's horrible to this kid it's
one thing to be okay you're bullying
you're in trouble you've got the
principal's office nothing to have on
your record as a 12 year old that you're
a sexual harasser yes it's insane it is
insane and it's good you could if you
had a good 401k
[Laughter]
yeah nobody talked to me about that when
i was 12. just saying you know
greg's a capitalist yeah it's true
yeah you got to be you got to get the fu
money larry so they can't cancel you and
the great thing about market economics
is there are no pronouns yeah that is
true
that is true
all right we got a roll what a great a
block and what a great night huh who am
i talking to you
up next netflix tells workers take a
hike if it's their content they don't
like
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else